Kevin Frazier in Las Vegas because he
has a very special guest camera here on
the terrace of the Omni a night club
with Cara Delevingne
and last night big night in Los Angeles
for you you had a private screening of
your new trailer for your movie valerian
with folks like Kendall Jenner and Jaden
Smith but yeah that was a lot of fun
wasn't it but now you're gonna hook up
our EP audience with something right
yeah you're gonna get a sneak peek at
the new trailer we need the two of you
to be the guardians of our future what
about the physicality of this role as
you are I mean you're tough in this
movie I enjoyed it a lot cuz learning
you know she saves the world that isn't
her job so to be able to you know I I
wanted to walk out everyday I like it
love Luke wasan directed the film Dane
DeHaan plays the title role cards Laura
lein and they are two operatives in the
massive city called alpha pull Erin
trust me last night what did your
friends think of at the screen when they
think of it she won't real so excited
they were already really happy they were
like I need to move it out there was sir
panic yeah they were were they came up
with it yes I'd never really heard of it
honestly but yeah it's based off of
these 70s French comics called valerian
and Laura lein it's definitely way more
epic than anything I've ever been
involved with you know it really is a
space opera Karen Dane are charged with
maintaining order among the humans we
have such a kind of fun flirtatious
energy in the movie and that's just kind
of what we tried to keep going all the
way through in flow
look for Rihanna she does a quick change
tell me about casting Rihanna
you called cast Rihanna you have to ask
the goddess she really wants to do it
the movie looks fantastic thank you for
coming out hanging out with thank you
like having me want to send it back to
Hollywood thank you Kevin
[Music]